Monsieur le premier ministre, bonjour.
Bonjour
Pour commencer, merci de nous accorder cette interview exclusive
Écoutez, c'est bien normal. Vous savez le pays traverse une période de crise,
et je voudrais que les français me fassent confiance, fassent confiance aux ministres,
et fassent confiance au président de la République. Et pour cela je voudrais que...
[Fou rire]
Le mec... Le mec il est fringué,
la vie de ma mère, on dirait qu'il va à un entretien d'embauche !
Non mais je rigole ! Je l'adore, c'est mon chéri, je l'adore. Il revient quand il veut.
Hé, alors Manu, on va être sérieux deux secondes.
J'ai lu sur le blog de Jean-Marc Morandini,
à ce qu'il paraît, y'en a un que tu peux pas sacquer dans la villa.
- Euh la villa ?
- Ouais, Matignon, fais pas l'hypocrite,
j'ai lu, à ce qu'il paraît
tu peux pas sacquer le ministre de l'Intérieur.
C'est vrai ou pas ? Balance ! Les gens ils veulent savoir. C'est vrai ?
- Écoutez, je ne vois pas pourquoi je mentirais aux Français.
- Hé ouais parce que mentir, c'est pas bien !
Haha ! Hein, pas vrai les kidous ?
[Cris d'enfants]
- Hahaha !
- Bien sûr. Bon écoutez, je pense qu'on s'éloigne du débat...
- Ah ben voilà. Ça, c'est très bien. Là c'est mon domaine.
Allez y, posez-moi vos questions.
- Afin d'établir un bilan,
au bout de cette première année
où vous avez investi le poste de premier ministre, j'aimerais vous poser
trois questions très claires.
- Comment bien soigner un herpès ?
- Est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un joli classico cette année ?
- Ma question préférée,
comment dépenser cette monnaie ?
- En tout cas j'ai beaucoup de mal à me faire comprendre des Français.
[Cris]
- D'accord. Cette mascarade a trop duré. Moi, j'en ai marre.
En plus maintenant, vous êtes un cheval. Ça n'a aucun sens.
Si les Français veulent s'informer, vaut mieux pas qu'ils regardent la télévision.
- Tout de suite, Les Ch'tis.